pfizer says it expects to more than
double the 5 million covet 19 vaccine
doses per week
that is currently providing to the u.s
government the drug makers
ceo made the commitment on friday during
a visit by president biden to its
kalamazoo michigan production facility
mr biden said that would put the nation
on track to have doses
available to all americans by the end of
july but he cautioned that any sense of
normalcy may still be many months away
christina ruffini is at the white house
christina good morning
good morning well while we all wait for
that return to normal life
president biden is trying to normalize
relations with european allies
telling them in his first big foreign
policy speech yesterday
that america has their back on a visit
to a pfizer production plant in michigan
president biden urged americans to roll
up their sleeves and do their part
to fight coronavirus the vaccines are
safe
please for yourself your family your
community
this country take the vaccine when it's
your turn and available
earlier in the day the president told
european leaders
that america will do its part america
is back both to support global health
efforts
and rebuild its reputation abroad i know
the past few years have strained and
tested
our transatlantic relationship but the
united states is determined
determined to re-engage with europe
backing up those vows of multilateralism
mr biden pledged 4 billion dollars to
kovacs
the global vaccine initiative and the
u.s
officially rejoined the paris climate
agreement a move
hailed by other signatories it's great
by the way that
joe has brought the united states back
into the paris
climate change accord he also brought
back tough talk against russia
something his predecessor tended to
avoid
the kremlin attacks our democracies and
weaponizes corruption to try to
undermine
our system of governance russian leaders
want people to think that our system is
more corrupt or as corrupt as theirs
but the world knows that isn't true and
he said the world was facing an
inflection point
our system of government versus theirs
and i believe that
every ounce of my being that democracy
will
and must prevail we must demonstrate
that democracy can still
deliver for our people in this changed
world
now that might seem like a tough sell
funding vaccine efforts abroad when most
americans still haven't gotten their
shot
but this is a global pandemic and health
experts will tell you
having the having the virus in any
country threatens
every country including the united
states dana yeah christina
interconnectivity we are looking forward
by the way to your piece when we roll
into our
number two double dip from chris sorry
guys thanks